on Prime crime
news
when plans are set in motion she's not
very Cooperative but I'm just gonna have
to uh put a bullet in her hair myself
the evidence points in all different
directions there was plausible
deniability with respect to what he
wanted he asked me are you wearing a
wire
[Music]
hey there everybody I'm Jesse Weber and
welcome to Prime crime this is where we
break down the most high profile and
memorable True Crime cases now anybody
who follows this program knows we focus
a lot on recordings like 911 phone calls
body cam footage interrogations but the
recordings in this case tell a whole
different kind of story the question is
what exactly is that story
what's going on
it's around 3 A.M on March 10th 2017 in
Houston Texas
police arrive at the home of
veterinarian Valerie McDaniel
[Music]
turns out to be a fatality
looks like one of them police are
referring to Valerie's ex Marion Mack
McDaniel
I was at the house
I called the police
where's your daughter now
anyone that's here to start oh my
boyfriend's here at one point Valerie's
boyfriend Leon Jacob comes into the room
oh my God might have been a robbery
going wrong
as police break the news of the death of
McDaniel to the couple they also asked
more about the two I'm a doctor here too
what kind of doctor are you I'm an
unlicensed transplant surgeon so have
you ever practiced yeah I just haven't
practiced in a while his medical career
was interesting he did not go to medical
school here in the states so he sought a
degree elsewhere and then tried on two
separate occasions to secure a medical
degree or standing within the states and
by all accounts they were met with poor
work performance
and was he worried about anything
I let him once but let's rewind
three days earlier
how you doing buddy very good Hey listen
I I'm gonna set up a meeting with you
tomorrow so we can finish this okay
and I'm gonna bring with me the the Navy
SEAL guy because he wants you know so so
we can get this done on this recorded
call Jacob is speaking with army veteran
Motes Aza AKA Zach we're taking care of
both problems about both problems
one of the individuals that we're
talking about
I think about my issue and Valerie's
issue it would later be revealed those
two people Jacob was referring to are
Valerie's X Mac and Leon's ex-girlfriend
Megan varicos
he'll take care of them you'll take care
of both of them the next day Zach meets
with Jacob and McDaniel at an Olive
Garden it's there when Zach introduces
the couple to a third person
[Music]
it's internally
I don't want them
there's only one problem for Jacob and
McDaniel that third man wasn't who he
seemed to be this is Officer Duran with
the Houston Police Department I will be
meeting suspect Leon Jacob
and Valerie McDaniel they have to listen
soliciting me to commit murder I was
assigned to the major offenders division
the way that I was brought into this
investigation is there's a a bondsman
who also happens to be a city of Houston
council member his name is Michael
Kubosh he was approached by Leon Jacob
he's told Mr Kubosh that he was looking
for a guy named Zach whom he had paid a
lot of money to to take care of some
problems and Mr Kubosh
felt very
uneasy with those questions so he
contacted the police department
Valerie wants to talk to you about what
she wants to do with her ex-husband okay
that's good
look Megan are we taking care of too
this week
yeah Motas was actually the original
Hitman he wasn't going to actually kill
her he was just stringing Leon along for
money when we found out about the murder
for higher plot we contacted montage and
he became a cooperating witness and his
purpose was to introduce me to Leon so
that I can become the new Hitman I want
that taken care of ASAP too no we'll
take care of it
Jacob reveals to undercover officer
Duran the trouble that not only McDaniel
was having with her ex including a
custody battle
but also at the time varicos had taken
out a protective order against Jacob for
allegedly assaulting and stalking her
and was planning to testify against him
my illegal to go away and this isn't the
first time Jacob has run into problems
he had a market History of Violence
towards women and acting out
did not get his head his way yet what
exactly is Leon Jacob asking for as far
as my situation goes I
[Music]
I don't need to see anything they're
going to come after me they're not going
to
Houston Texas
2017. authorities are investigating Leon
Jacob and his girlfriend Valerie
McDaniel they suspect the couple of
orchestrating a murder For Hire plot one
target being Mac McDaniel Valerie's
ex-husband the other Jacob's
ex-girlfriend Megan varicos in fact at
the time Jacob was facing felony charges
of stalking and assaulting varicos but
little did Jacob and McDaniel realize
that the person they're speaking with is
actually undercover police officer
Javier Duran
here too but I you know I gotta trust
you okay what you need to understand
from my side I'm worrying about being
for the phone that's how people get
caught on the phone Duran was introduced
to the two through cooperating witness
Motes Zach azza and the conversations
between Jacob and Duran are interesting
email
this is a burner phone
that's clear the fact that he told me he
was using a burner phone and that he was
using an alias told me that
he was serious about this and then there
was the money Trail Motas was paid ten
thousand dollars and two Cartier watches
and a laptop at least you start I'll
need the 2500 payment just get it done
you'll get
when I agreed with Valerie and Leon to
kill Mac McDaniel we agreed it'd be an
additional fee of ten thousand dollars
it's clear that this wasn't not a
fleeting concept that just entered into
his mind but something that over time he
was willing to pay for to achieve
however what exactly did Jacob think he
was paying for is this really a case of
him soliciting a murder when you're
doing a murder for higher investigation
you want to make sure that they're
actually planning to go through with the
murder sometimes you find out that the
person
who is looking to have somebody killed
they were just angry at the time in that
case the investigation is pretty much
over
I could get him out of the picture real
quick
Leon's very intelligent he was being
very cautious with the words that he
would use so he never came out and said
you know I want her dead I want you to
kill her he also would say things like I
don't want her hurt I understand that
you don't want her hurt I know that she
just wanted to leave
there was plausible deniability with
respect to what he wanted to have
achieved Jacob clearly laid out other
than fatal options for the intended
target and specifically he mentioned
having her go out of town having drugs
planted on her
but at the same time he would make
comments like inject her in the heart
with potassium chloride he would also
ask me to kidnap her where do you take
her to talk to either a storage unit
but then we thought about
the cameras cameras tons of cameras
we'll be honest with you now what's
better on her coming back alive
I already just wanted to leave get in
her car
I think that plays into his mental
illness and his personality disorders he
spent some time in a facility here in
Houston he was treated for uh
narcissistic behavior bipolar and a
couple other syndromes I don't think he
understood the consequences of what he
was doing the question of whether Jacob
actually wanted Megan and Mac dead would
become even more complicated by what
happened next
week in so many words I don't give a
anymore I'm willing to do what I
need to do to make sure this doesn't get
away with what he's done
foreign
[Music]
people have requested messages some
people want their target to get hit you
know shot 10 times in the head or
something whatever
in 2017 authorities are conducting an
elaborate sting operation of Leon Jacob
and his girlfriend Valerie McDaniel out
in Houston Texas they believe the couple
are orchestrating a murder For Hire plot
against their respective exes Megan
varicos and Mac McDaniel what Jacob and
McDaniel don't realize is that the
person posing as a Hitman is actually
undercover police officer Javier Duran
there's something else we can do which
is where her body
won't be held I'm gonna be honest with
you I need to protect myself
what's your real name
I don't know that's your real name or
not Duran has to make sure though that
Jacob and McDaniel are actually
soliciting a murder and that's when
authorities take a dramatic step in this
operation well my friend this is why I
was trying to tell you I have some good
news for you but I need to meet you mack
assisted Us by faking his own death we
took him to a secure location from there
we staged and murder in his real vehicle
the male subjects I'm sure you know what
I'm talking about he's gone he's done
all right he's done when I met Leon and
Valerie to tell them about mag uh Mac is
dead he's gone I have a picture
he didn't really say much he just looked
at it and shook his head up and down
his immediate reaction to that he asked
me are you wearing a wire it shows that
he was very cautious
for his own safety so he did check my
shirt I was wearing
more than one recording device
I was not wearing a wire luckily I was
not wearing one of those and Mac
McDaniel wasn't the only cooperating
participant in this operation for Megan
we actually staged her kidnapping we
took Megan to a secure location which in
this case was a garage and zip tied her
hands you know we had to make it look
very real I sent you a picture of her do
you want me to take care of her myself
you have to do that you should see how
how Megan is acting she's uh
yeah she's not very Cooperative I'm just
gonna have to uh put a bullet in her
hair myself
I need an answer
I'm pretty sure she knows I'm not
playing with her officer Duran takes
another step in this stage scheme
hey bud I just wanted to let you know uh
there's there's no reasoning with her
you know put too much risk on on us
that's pretty much it man she's uh she's
dead she's gone yeah
Gonna Come Back absolutely nothing I'm
taking care of everything as we speak
right now he immediately went into
protection mode he never expressed any
type of regret he never expressed any
type of anger at me you know why would
you do this to Megan I told you not to
do this he was concerned with himself
and that brings us back once again to
the early morning hours of March 10th if
anybody knows anything
[Music]
that reaction was priceless because you
could see immediately what we now
recognized is feigned shock we've been
here all night we were watching movies
we haven't been out of the house all day
it leads a lot to be desired in the
realm of acting right now we're going to
read you your rights because both of you
being arrested this solicitation Captain
word why this person murdered we you
know we learned the Marine silent I
walked inside of the living room and
they both looked up at me and both of
their faces just fell to the ground they
knew that they were in really big
trouble
but how strong of a case is this really
up next the trial is on did you ever pay
money for the purpose of harming or
hurting either Megan or may Daniel no
[Music]
I mean I don't know why I'm being
arrested okay well he just told you
down in Houston Texas Leon Jacob and his
girlfriend Valerie McDaniel are arrested
and charged with solicitation of murder
police say the two attempted to hire a
hitman to kill their exes Megan varicos
and Marion Mack McDaniel but the two
didn't realize the man they were dealing
with was actually undercover police
officer Sergeant Javier Duran I need an
answer
foreign
however something happens with Valerie
McDaniel before she ever steps foot in
front of a jury when she was arrested
she took the DraStic step of taking her
own life and when her friends and family
were spoken to afterwards they firmly
and consistently blamed her interaction
with Jacob but that didn't halt the
prosecution of Leon Jacob and his
criminal trial began in 2018. he knew
exactly what Valerie wanted she was
sitting right there when the officer
said this is what she wants this is how
we're going to do it I need the payment
and Leon immediately offers the payment
and that night he wants it done he wants
it done right then the prosecution used
the tapes to support their version of
the events she showed me this time this
time do it yeah I do Reasonable Doubt is
all over the place
where the ACT is all instigated
by the police department the defense
argued that really he had never intended
this murder and that the undercover
officer Through Time had baited him and
made him believe that the only option to
achieve his results to not have this
woman testify against him was murder you
had to talk to him I don't know if
talking is going to do much help at this
point the jury heard from multiple
Witnesses connected to the case but all
eyes were on the defendant Leon Jacob
when he took the stand at the time I was
not 100 of what those Services were
because Valerie had made that
negotiation with him Jacob has
repeatedly that it was really Valerie's
idea
Valerie because we have a difference of
opinion about that and of course Valerie
is not here to posit her version of the
events at trial I never asked anybody to
kill anybody
177 times during these trans these
conversations do I say the words I don't
want to harm or hurt or kill anybody
Jacob is
intelligent individual and he is
carefully crafted
what he was trying to say while he was
on the stand when you tell the members
of this jury that you're heart sick over
Megan that's not really true is it I
have no problem sitting here and saying
that I slept with Valerie seven days
after Megan and I broke up but I'm not
on trial for being a womanizer I'm on
trial facilitation of capital murder he
could not control his anger and I think
the district attorney Samantha connect I
think she did a great job you told
Javier snatcher put her in a room and
tell her if she doesn't believe I'm
gonna kill her parents right
if that's what you say I said did you
say it Mr Jacob
sure regardless of the evidence that's
presented at trial it's really anybody's
game what the jury will think with the
jury find the defendant Leon Philip
Jacob guilty of solicitation of capital
murder is charged in the indictment we
the jury find the defendant Leon Philip
Jacob guilty of solicitation of capital
murder is charged in the indictment
personally I've really seen a case that
had so much videographic
against the criminal defendant we the
jury having found the defendant Leon
Phillip Jacob guilty of solicitation of
capital murder assess this punishment at
confinement in the institutional
division of the Texas Department of
Criminal Justice For Life assessifying
in the amount of ten thousand dollars
Leon has filed a writ of habeas corpus
with the Court of Criminal Appeals we
are awaiting a decision on that case
he's claiming that his trial attorney
was ineffective the trial attorney
should have
told him that there was no defense and
that he should have
pled guilty and put on a punishment case
I think he's got a fairly good chance of
getting a new punishment hearing
you manipulated me to leave my family
in the life I had
I believe everything happens for a
reason
while you sit in jail I hope you think
of me
the girl that you called for and
uneducated
because it's because of me you will be
in prison for life it's my belief that I
don't think he could live with the fact
that she didn't want him he's Leon Jacob
he's the God's gift to women and he
couldn't believe that he was turned down
by this girl and I think he wanted Mack
out of the picture so that Valerie
didn't have to pay him any of the money
ultimately I believe that Leon's
motivation is just greed and vanity
despite Jacob's attempts to show he
didn't mean what he said on those tapes
it didn't really work and the jury
convicted him
now here's something to consider
imagine if officer Duran wasn't there
imagine this wasn't an undercover
operation imagine this was all for real
what could have ended up happening to
two people is very scary to think about
that's all we have for you here on Prime
crime as always thank you for joining us
and until next time stay safe
[Music]
thank you
foreign